we are off on a sunset adventure free
where are we going haleakala crater
that's where we're going the original
plan the sunrise Lily did plan on
sunrise but that clearly didn't happen
so now we're gonna hop in the car drive
about two and a half hours hopefully we
don't hit traffic and we get to see the
sunset
for making our first stop we need to get
some coffee with almost to the place
this way I didn't bring any money but I
would like to say hello five coffees
five boxes
[Music]
we need Bria Sarah Nene I think I've got
all the gear to cover this riveting
event
Bree told us if you called but I didn't
really believe how cold it would be
[Music]
3,000 feet man I can't breathe it is
onion oh I told you I'm going I'm
suffering for the shot because I gotta
get this time-lapse suffer for the shot
[Music]
seconds I like dancing that absurd so I
do I bother but nothing can compete with
the way it hurts when they see your
recover
[Music]
whose plane
you
we gotta go we gotta go girl it's cool
[Music]
okay thanks
these things I'm gonna make this week
they are these weird little teeth Apple
they look like this I really don't have
any directions so basically just gonna
try to replicate that I've got my apples
and we're gonna just we're gonna do it
we're gonna cut them so we're able the